today we're talking about a possible new
star wars game being in development how
battlefield 2042 is not in trouble
despite being delayed and how split gate
is getting a feature before halo
infinite my name is devonte chisholm and
you're watching gamespot news
let's kick this one off with some star
wars rumors because there is reportedly
a new game in the works and this one is
said to be developed by quantic dream
the dev behind games like heavy rain and
detroit become human the rumor began
when french youtuber gautas
so sorry if i'm saying your name wrong
so sorry posted a video in which he
claimed that quantic dream might be
working on a star wars game the story
was then picked up by vgc and shortly
after tom henderson of dual shockers
posted an article stating that an
independent source provided evidence
that the game was real and had been in
development for the past 18 months and
adding to all of this kotaku was also
able to corroborate this from its own
sources the star wars game in question
is supposedly different from quantic
dream's other quick time event heavy
games like detroit become human instead
the game will have more traditional
gameplay possibly in an open world
environment and with multiplayer
elements however at the time of this
recording quantic dream has not made any
public comment about the rumors or made
an official announcement so take this
all with a grain of salt just you know
temper those expectations until an
official announcement is or isn't made
switching gears to battlefield 2042 now
because despite the game's delay last
week it is not in trouble on twitter
principal software engineer jim hegel
said there is no reason to worry about
battlefield and the game just needs
quote a little longer on spin cycle jim
also added he is spending time working
on adjusting 2040s 2 to terrain
tessellation systems and that the game
is being developed on a 24-hour basis
thanks to the team having devs spread
across the world and when it comes to
audience reception of battlefield 2042
jim told the fan like any other creative
endeavor some people might not love what
dice brings to the table with the new
game has 2042 lessened your excitement
for the game let me know in the comments
below
and now let's talk about battlefield's
competitor call of duty because
vanguard's open beta was extended the
public test was supposed to end today
september 20th but will now end on
september 22nd and that's the good news
the bad news however is that players are
already dealing with hackers these
hackers are reportedly ruining matches
with the usual mix of cheats such as
aimbot and wallhacks to see and shoot
opponents through walls
some players are also posting clips of
hackers ending the match early which are
abruptly concluded with the message that
the host ended the game hacking in the
vanguard beta is very concerning but
hopefully the cheaters will be better
kept at bay once call of duty's new
anti-cheat system arrives later this
year with integration of the new warzone
pacific map
and moving right along to split gate
last week the developer 1047 games
announced they raised 10 million dollars
in funding to help support its ambitions
in a statement ceo ian prouse said quote
i am happy to confirm that we are not
selling our company to one of the big
guys this week split gate is continuing
to make headlines by announcing it will
get a ford style map editor mode before
halo infinite does
responding to a tweet from kfc's gaming
account to quote trigger an entire
gaming fan base with one sentence the
split gate account replied with a
message about forge and said quote split
gate will have forge mode before halo
infinite sorry in advance halo fans we
love you but we had to
earlier this year 343 industries
confirmed that forge will not launch
with halo infinite in december but is
instead coming sometime later alongside
campaign co-op which will also
misrelease and launch later in the
future so let me know in the comments
down below if you're really excited for
the possibility of this new star wars
game i mean we already have news that
is working on a new knights of the old
republic and then ubisoft's working on a
star wars game so like we're we're just
getting a bunch of them at once is it
too much is it let me know let me know
i'm out of here i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
you